[Musique]
l'entité qui se trouve ici le plateau de
paris saclay est une entité dit bm de
tête un centre de co-innovation et qui
regroupe dans un premier temps une
équipe de développement logiciel
une équipe de recherche est également
une équipe de consulting l'équipe de
recherche que nous avons ici travaillent
sur des systèmes auto apprenant que nous
lions à des systèmes de moteurs de
règles business et qui permettent
d'appréhender des sujets tout à fait
nouveau en iran et puis nous avons
l'équipe de conseil qui va accompagner
nos clients sur tous leurs initiatives
d'innovation
au sens large
en termes de recherche quand on est à
plusieurs dès qu'on échange avec
d'autres personnes on avance plus vite
c'est pour ça que nous retrouvons ici
dans ce site tous ces ingrédients qui
sont propices pour toutes les personnes
qui souhaitent faire de l'innovation
nous avons ici un sourcing de cerveau
les écoles produisent des ingénieurs
avec un niveau reconnu mondialement qui
fait partie des meilleurs dans le monde
académique nous avons des labos de
recherche à la fois académique et
industriel dans ce lieu de paris saclay
avec qui nous échangeons régulièrement
ce que nous cherchons à développer tout
particulièrement ici à sac les cds
partenariat tripartite c'est ce qu'on
doit commencer à faire avec à la fois
d'un côté ses labos de recherche et des
industriels et d'autre part des
académiques et les ingénieurs qui se
trouvent aux chesneaux en recherche et
aujourd'hui les partenariats que nous
développons nous en sommes convaincus
vont permettre de d'avancer beaucoup
plus vite en termes d'innovation et de
ce que nous pouvons offrir à nos clients
le plateau de paris saclay offre aux
entreprises comme nos des interactions
la grande valeur ajoutée avec tout cet
écosystème de la boe de recherche c'est
pour ça que ce site est un lieu
incontournable pour toutes les
entreprises françaises ou
internationales qui souhaitent se
retrouver dans le creuset
d'innovation technologique et de et de
recherche qui est aujourd'hui un élément
essentiel notamment dans l'intelligence
artificielle
[Musique]